l affaire un pégase y sont on en débat
tout de suite avec nos invités dominique
pradalié secrétaire général snj et pedro
luiz as responsable numérique république
souveraine
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france pedro gonesse
d'abord les téléphones de plusieurs
hauts responsables politiques français
donc auraient pu être infectés par le
logiciel d'espionnage israéliens utilisé
par le maroc dont celui d'ailleurs du
chef de l'état est ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter pour la sécurité française
et la possible fuite d'informations
sensibles à tout d'abord alors tout
d'abord il faut comprendre que depuis
2001 et bien avant en particulier 2001
le patriot act
des données qui transitent par les
téléphones six ehpad et effets spéciaux
sécurisé etc sont interceptés donc ça
c'est pour dire un état de fait on l'a
vu c'est dans les révélations dé voir si
nos jeunes avec le programme prisme au 6
juin à sang etc
on sait que une grande partie de la
population mondiale et en particulier
c'était le cas de madame merkel et à
l'époque de françois hollande sont
espionnés donc on va dire ça y'a rien de
nouveau là dessus ce qui est nouveau
c'est que des petits pays comme le maroc
qui n'avait pas cette capacité on va
dire de d'armes de guerre de
surveillance massy puissent le faire et
donc puisse acheter des technologies qui
permettent de le faire
donc effectivement ça c'est quelque
chose qui aujourd'hui est nouveau est-ce
que ça pose un problème on ose espérer
que nos dirigeants n'utilise à leur
smartphone privé pour faire transiter
des données sensibles
maintenant c'est beaucoup plus
préoccupant pour la question des
journalistes
et vis-à-vis de la liberté d'expression
et la protection ces journalistes de
leurs sources puisque ils ont pas les
mêmes moyens que les politiques pour
pouvoir se protéger ce genre de choses
dominique pradalié des hauts
responsables français mais des
journalistes aussi que vous inspire la
sphère pegasus écouter ce qui est très
inquiétant
c'est de considérer qu effectivement
près de quinze jours après cette
révélation
aucune information aucune réponse aux
questions multiples nous nous posons est
ce si je puis êtes d'accord avec la
deuxième partie de l'intervention de de
la personne qui que vous avez invité de
rugby big souveraine je suis pas eu
d'accord pour dire que ce n'est pas
nouveau est inquiétant c'est que depuis
2015 où les révélations des douars sna
holden sur l'espionnage et de tous les
chefs d'état ou presque européen par là
les services américains
il n'y a eu aucune disposition de prise
aucune disposition entreprises et délais
cette époque là emmanuel macron dit ray
jeux je vais en appeler à la tâte à ce
que toute la clarté soit faite
c'était il ya six ans et a aucune clarté
n'a été faite premièrement deuxièmement
aucune disposition n'a été prise
aucune aucune je vois par exemple le
luxembourg vous direz c'est un petit
pays mais c'est pas pour autant qu'il
manque de dignité d'honneur et de
réactivité
le ministre des affaires étrangères qui
s'appelle jean asselborn
interviewé par le monde a dit qu'il
avait immédiatement pris contact avec
les plus grandes firmes du pays etc etc
pour leur interdire de commercer avec
des logiciels qui permettent de de te
mettre en cause tous les droits humains
dans sont payés dans d'autres pays
d'ailleurs je voudrais dire aussi que il
s'agit là d'une affaire mondiale et que
ça confirme malheureusement puisque le
logiciel est présenté comme étant
quelque chose pour se débarrasser des
terroristes elle confirme toutes les
lois notamment en france
restrictives de liberté depuis 2015 la
loi renseignements la loi sécurité
globale elle boit séparatisme la loi sur
la responsabilité pénale et la sécurité
intérieure toutes ces lois ont été
prises pour combattre le terrorisme est
en fait elles sont utilisées pour
combattre les opposants un exemple au
togo par exemple dans le monde également
on voit que 300 numéros togolaise
servent à la cible et le mot est juste
là les opposants dont il est du
terrorisme rade à liévin on va faire
réagir
pedro guen s sur la question vous posiez
pourquoi est ce que finalement au niveau
de l'état français on semble pas vouloir
faire grand bruit de la sphère pegasus
pour l'instant malgré les demandes de de
la presse 1 pour des clarifications
comment vous l'expliquez c'est assez
simple faut savoir que la france est un
des premiers pays vendeurs de ce type de
technologie on se souvient du scandale
amesys ou necsa technologie faut savoir
qu'ils ont été mis certains dirigeants
été mis en examen s'est récemment en cas
de l'espionnage des opposants en libye
ou en egypte
et si je me trompe pas il avait voulu
vendre aussi la technologie à l'époque
du printemps arabe en tunisie et donc
l'état français dans ce type de
technologie donc c'est vrai qu'on est
embêté de taper sur les israéliens
puisque nous mêmes on fait ça et souvent
alors à nouveau sous prétexte de
terrorisme
on vend sans problème pour espionner les
opposants politiques des journalistes
donc c'est vrai que je pense que le
silence de l'état en fait en réalité
c'est ce qu'on serait bien embêtée dire
les israéliens ont été les étapes
ils font ça sont des états voyous
puisque nous mêmes on n'a aucune morale
à le faire et ça c'est un vrai problème
c'est à dire que moi je considère que
ces outils de surveillance globale est
absente dire que c'est des armes de
guerre
c'était on est dans des processus
effectivement qui permet de faire du
ciblage qui permette d'arrêter des gens
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas anodin
leurs écrits tiens ça ne tue pas comme
les armes de destruction massive ou les
âmes des bactéries mais c'est
redoutablement efficace et par rapport à
ça effectivement nous en tant qu'etat
français en tant que vendeur d'armes
puisqu'on vend ses armes la baisse on
est très embêté et pour moi on va dire
un peu à comme à l'époque avec les mines
antipersonnel qui était une horreur
absolue
il devrait y avoir un moratoire
international sur la vente de ce type
d'armes
c'est à tous les états du monde vrai
dire non on ne peut pas vendre ce type
d'armes parce que de toute façon ce sera
utilisé à mauvais desseins faire que
l'on peut toujours trouver toutes les
justifications
mais ce sera toujours détourné et ce
sera l on va dire que les états qui
veulent combattre théorique développent
leurs propres outils
c'est une chose maintenant d'en faire un
commerce lucratif
ça c'est vraiment c'est quelque chose il
s'interroger pedro gonesse devait
évoquer justement les liens étroits
entre la france et israël un logiciel
pegasus d'un logiciel israélien utilisé
par le maroc de milly pradalié il ya
aussi le lien étroit entre la france et
le maroc
finalement cette affaire aussi qu'est ce
qu'elle révèle sur le respect de la
liberté de la presse au maroc notamment
mais aussi en france
elle révèle malheureusement ce que nous
clamons depuis quelques années à savoir
que la liberté de la presse n'est plus
du tout une priorité pour la majorité
actuelle ou pouvoir elle l'a prouvé par
toutes ces lois contre lesquels nous
nous battons avec succès d'ailleurs pour
le moment mais qui risque de revenir
d'un autre côté nous ne voulons pas être
considérés comme des terroristes comme
le sont nos confrères marocains
actuels qui sont emprisonnés pourri
trajet l'état et cetera c'est pour ça
que nous mettons au côté en justice nous
sommes du côté de edwy plenel et notre
consoeur de mediapart qui ont porté
plainte dans cette affaire pegasus et si
le maroc portent plainte contre
forbidden stories qui a révélé la sphère
et amnesty
le snj se portera aussi à leurs côtés le
juge doit dire qu' on ne peut pas
espionné indûment et en toute impunité
des journalistes des hommes politiques
des opposants quel qu'il soit alors pour
éviter ces dérapages pedro gonesse
que faut-il faire est ce qu'on peut
attendre aussi de la part aujourd'hui de
l'état français une réaction ferme et
des mesures concrètes
concrètement si on était dans un système
normal l'espionnage d'un autre pays à ce
niveau là en particulier de ses
dirigeants ou en matière de personnes
d'intérêt c'est ça pour être considéré
loin de la guerre froide c'était des
années de guerre c'est pas quelque chose
d'anodin
on sait que effectivement depuis la fin
de l'union soviétique
la plupart de l'espionnage a été fait
pour des questions économiques en
particulier en souvient du cas d'alcatel
d'alstom et cetera qui ont été
espionnées ou même vers buste par les
états unis mais c'était pour des raisons
économiques ou les chinois ils font
beaucoup
maintenant on sait que là dessus dans
cas du maroc c'est je pense pas que ce
soit pour des raisons économiques et
fécamp c'est dans une logique de se
maintenir au pouvoir et de faire taire
toute opposition ça là dessus c'est
clair ce qui est sûr c'est que le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui à la tête
de notre état
on a des gens qui ne font plus confiance
à la puissance de l'état pour résoudre
les problèmes des gens qui me font
confiance qu'au privé donc ils attendent
du privé des initiatives pour nous
protéger
ça alors que l'état est comme le dit
très bien madame c'était c1 lui de
planifier ça faisait des deux ça fait
des années
que de nombreuses personnes dont notre
mouvement mais aussi d'autres mouvements
dit il est temps que la france donne
d'outils capables de se protéger
ce genre d'attaqué pour puisse les
fournir librement aussi bien à nos
armées cirque c'est inadmissible que nos
armées aujourd'hui ce service des
systèmes microsoft alors qu'on sait très
clairement aux puits révélation snowdon
et d'assange que c'est des outils qui
sont complètement vérolé par les
services secrets américains
on devrait on a la capacité lancy fait
un certain nombre de choses mais c'est
largement insuffisant c'est quelque
chose
les russes par contre eux ont investi en
masse pour se protéger de ce genre de
chose les chinois le fond nous on en
reste à regarder en partant du principe
que ce sont des puissances a mis entre
guillemets et donc elles ne veulent pas
de mal c'est quand même une très grande
naïveté on peut s'y interroge quand même
sur en haut de l'état qu'elle connivence
on a et quelle complaisance vis-à-vis de
ça comme l'a dit madame depuis
l'histoire de l'espionnage en guerre à
merkel ou même de françois hollande a eu
aucune sanction personnes procès même
pas de sanction on va dire économique
rien on a juste dit c'est pas bien et
c'est tout alors justement il ya des
blagues et du tout à l'heure il ya des
représentants des médias qui vont donner
des suites encore à cette affaire des
suites judiciaires
qu'espérez-vous au final nous nous avons
besoin d'une législation nationale nous
avons aussi besoin d'une législation
européenne et madame verra jour
vaquaient 10 présente comme vous le
savez de la commission européenne
annoncé toute une série de mesures
issues du constat de la halle de l'état
de la liberté de la presse en europe qui
devrait de notre point de vue inclure
une mesure extrême des mesures
extrêmement fortes pour empêcher et
punir si on ne peut pas empêcher ce type
de pratiques
je suis tout à fait en accord avec
monsieur des taux sur cette intervention
précédente
c'est un acte ce sont des actes de
guerre et vous disiez tout à l'heure ça
ne tue pas si ça tue au mexique ça tue
dans d'autres pays ça tue les
journalistes et les opposants bien
évidemment ce sont des actes de guerre
qui tue mais comme le disait l'autre les
guerres seront faites par des gens qui
s'entretuent ne se connaissent pas au
profit de gens qui se connaissent très
bien et qu'ils ne s'entretuent pas merci
beaucoup à vous à dominique pradalié
secrétaire générale du snj et pedro guen
s responsable numérique de la république
souveraine